foreign
[Music]
against 1941 okay
oh never mind we don't
I was looking forward to that one okay
berry apple pie 1746.
from Saint Kitts and Nevis wow I don't
think I've ever played someone from
Saint Kitts and Nevis all right C5
beautiful we get another chance to play
the elephant so far the elephant has
brought us tremendous success and almost
invariably either clearly better or
straight up winning positions out of the
opening eventually that's gonna change
and now you see that most people do
actually play one of the two main moves
either D5 or Knight F6 but it's not
enough to know that move you also have
to know the follow-up and previously we
did face
this line our opponent played Knight C6
Knight F3 and I'm trying to remember
what our opponent played there no it
actually might have been C takes D4 so C
takes D4 is one of several viable
continuations but it's an incredibly
risky line it's an incredibly risky line
and conceptually you could call it an
inaccuracy because after white
recaptures the Knight gets of course the
C3 Square
which will chase the queen away from D5
and ultimately hopefully allow us to set
the d-pawn in motion yeah so the last uh
alapan game we had which is now on
YouTube continued Knight C6 we're
following that game
and after Knight F3 our opponent played
Bishop G4 we might follow that game for
a while
so of course black attacks the pawn on
T4 we need to defend it and in the
analysis to that game I went pretty deep
into the main line here so there's E5
which is the main alternative and then
there's Bishop G4
black can also play E6 but then you know
black is slightly well black is probably
clearly worse after we play Knight C3
and in that other YouTube video
I showcased the line where after Bishop
G4 white is not supposed to play the
obvious Bishop B2 but instead you go
directly Knight C3 our opponent in that
game moved to the queen away we push D5
and we were already winning but the
testing line was Bishop G4 Knight C3 and
Bishop takes F3 I'll do a quick review
of it in this game as well just to
hammer the points home but our opponent
doesn't go for it he goes G6 as Extreme
as this may sound black is already
almost lost after this move
and not only that but our path toward
developing the initiative could not be
more obvious so the next move is begging
to be played we obviously bring our
night out with Tempo that's the whole
point
and that's why black should have done
this while keeping the pawns on C5 and
C3 that would have been a incomparably
better version for black because now we
get Knight C3 and once the queen moves
away unless it moves away to E6 because
that's a check we'll have to block it we
basically pre-move D5 against every
other Queen retreat
yeah this is uh this is a complete
disaster in fact the move G6 actually
makes things worse for black because if
black is unable to Fan quiero the bishop
as we've explored in other lines white
could actually bring the queen up to D4
hitting the rook in the corner
precluding Bishop G7 and that could make
matters even worse for black so this
merely gives us fuel for the fire
a better version of this type of line
would have been Knight F6 but still
after Knight C3 were overwhelmingly
better I think our opponent has realized
what has happened
and now he's trying to find the proper
retreating Square for the queen but
there is none
yeah so in this position I think
objectively the best line is E5 and
after E5 black is slightly worse
according to Modern Theory
I also showed that line in the previous
YouTube video but let's leave that until
after the game because right now let's
try to develop our initiative accurately
and once again it's important not to
delay right the the longer we delay the
less effective the move D5 becomes why
is that well if we play a nonchalant
developing move like Bishop E2 then that
allows black Defiance ghetto and if we
play D5 in that position well already
the Knight can move into E5 and black is
sort of stabilizes so definitely we want
to push D5 and really and then start
thinking this is not a very committal
move right it's not like we're taking a
big risk that pawn wants to be on D5
anyway and it's very well defended so
we're not sacrificing the pawn or taking
on any kind of positional or tactical
risk that's why you can make this move
largely without calculation
but there is still a lot of work to do
right the position's not going to win
itself and
black doesn't have any concrete targets
we're gonna have to use our development
advantage in our initiative and
ultimately transform that into either
some sort of material gain such as a
fork that would happen if black played
Knight before Queen A4 check would pick
up the Knight or more likely a direct
attack against the black king
so probably the only move here that I
see which doesn't lose material is
Knight back to B8 not an easy move to
play yeah and
black collapses immediately this walks
into a basic Betty type of idea anytime
the A4 E8 diagonal is open and there is
a knight on B4 that is undefended this
occurs in so many different openings but
one thing to avoid here would of course
be Queen D4 right I could see somebody
making this move and getting excited
about the fork and instead you're gonna
get forked yourself on C2 that's the
irony instead you check on A4 and the
game is over
nine moves
that's why I recommend the elephant and
we're at 1750 right these aren't potzers
these are pretty serious players but
people just don't study the elephant
it's just one of those underrated
anti-sicilians and people think of it as
oh you know you're just trying to avoid
Theory and get some sort of quiet
position not at all the elephant has
played in order to win the game out of
the opening yeah let's see if our
opponent resigns which is quite likely I
think
because not only are we winning the
night but black will not have a single
other piece developed so
yeah Knight C6 okay well this actually
hastens Black's defeat we technically we
could toy with black a little bit and we
could even just make like a development
move but why you know why do that why
not take the Knight okay black
recaptures now here we should invest a
couple moments because we want to win
quickly
we don't want to let black you know
survive needlessly and queen takes E6
check there's nothing wrong with that
move at all but after Bishop D7 black
chases the queen away with Tempo and
then black is able to bring the king
side pieces out and potentially even
castle and the game would drag on in
that case so if possible I want to find
some way to get to this King while it's
still in the center and there's a move
that I'm really eyeing because it sets
up tremendous threats against Black's
King yeah it's the move Knight E5 and
the reason I see it is because well
black hasn't fee and kettled yet right
so you're automatically kind of looking
at the squares that the bishop would
control if it had been on G7 and trying
to exploit uh the temporary lack of
Black's development Knight E5 I think is
super powerful what does it actually
threaten well of course the immediate
threat is Queen takes C6 check why is it
a threat because there after Bishop D7
we take on D7 with the Knight Queen
takes D7 drops the rook in the corner
and if black doesn't recapture well then
black is down two pieces and we have
potentially discovered checkmate
we're also sort of threatening Knight
takes Pawn
but that might be unnecessary because
they're black and go Queen D7 and we
don't have an effective discovery
although there we could perhaps bring
our light squared Bishop up and that
would also be totally winning
yeah probably black has to go Bishop D7
here and then I wouldn't even touch the
C6 Pawn we don't need that pawn anymore
we're already up a piece and we're
essentially trying to go for checkmate
here
and what it means to go for checkmate is
we are trying to develop our pieces as
actively and as quickly as possible so
if we have developing moves that can be
played with Tempo then we should
probably go for those
I'm going to look around and make sure
that there are no hidden tactics here
Knight F7 doesn't seem to work we don't
have enough pieces developed in order
for that to work now I think we have two
approaches here
one of them involves developing the king
side first and playing Bishop C4 forcing
E6 and then Castle in kingside and
trying to put a rook under one but I
think there is a slightly more accurate
way to play this which might yield a
quicker victory
so if we calculate the line Bishop C4 E6
Castle's King side when black plays
Bishop G7 he hits the Knight on E5 which
gives black one more Tempo so we're not
able to go Rook D1 there and I really
really there's nothing I would rather do
than put a piece on the D file and
really hit this bishop where it hurts so
there is a way to engineer this such
that we can guarantee ourselves a rook
on D1 and it's a weird move it may seem
like a weird move which is Bishop F4 but
if you understand the point of it it
becomes totally clear the point is to
protect the Knight while developing a
piece and of course to prepare long
Castle or Rook D1 but if we're already
putting a rook on D1 then why not Castle
why not talk our King away to safety
while we're at it so it feels like
Bishop F4 might be the more accurate
move
yeah and again remember the law of
diminishing returns when it comes to
material when you're up a minor piece
the value of an additional Pawn
is not very high so going out of our way
to win this Pawn on C6 is pretty foolish
especially when we have you know a much
bigger Ace up Our Sleeve which is our
development advantage you know if if
push comes to shove we can always
recover a couple of Pawns if need be but
we're uh we we've got bigger fish to fry
here if C5 then we take the bishop and
then we pin the queen with Bishop B5
that's not gonna not gonna help
yeah C5 C5 is not gonna help
and in response to Bishop G7 we will
Castle queenside
and attack the bishop on D7 and of
course their black can take our Knight
but that would involve giving away the
fianchetto bishop which is a total
positional disaster and I think that
would lose pretty quickly Knight F6 also
possible
Okay so well
you know what even before playing long
Castle we could also throw in the move
Bishop C4
but funnily enough inducing E6 might
actually in a weird way play into
Black's hands because if we throw in
Bishop C4 E6 and then we Castle black
and stick a knight on D5 and try to clog
up the D file using these two pawns as
supports whereas if we Castle
immediately Knight D5 doesn't work
because we take it then we take the
bishop and then we pin the queen with
Bishop B5 so we could play Bishop C4 it
doesn't ruin anything and actually now
that I think about it
just give me a second to calculate here
because Bishop C4 actually might be
worth playing there's a concrete line
there that needs to be investigated
yeah no I actually think we can get away
with Bishop C4
and there's a specific tactical reason
why let's throw this in let's throw this
in
forcing E6 and after long Castle in that
position if black tries Knight D5 then I
realized that we could simply take on D5
anyway
if black takes with a c Pawn in that
position then again we have the classic
idea Knight D7 and Bishop B5
whereas if black takes with the E Pawn
then that opens up the e-file and with
Black's King still in the center that is
going to be totally devastating we can
play Knight takes C6 and bring the Rook
to E1 I'll show all of these lines after
the game provided that our opponent
doesn't go for it but long story short
Knight D5 is not a solution to Black's
problems
he says Dinah let me get another one
this one doesn't count
I said okay I'm down to play one more if
he resigns promptly I am down to give
him a rematch
but let's see how long this game lasts
lasts for all right
so E6 castles yeah this is total
Massacre total Massacre yeah we could
also play Rook D1 obviously but I I like
the idea of castling because it puts the
King on a safer spot and it clears the
E1 Square so if black in fact plays
Knight D5 then after the trade we have
the capacity to play rookie one
immediately whereas if the King was
still on E1 we wouldn't be able to
exploit the e-file as quickly
so if possible the rule is that you
always want to do more than one thing
with each move right if you could if a
move can serve several purposes
then you know those are the kinds of
moves that you really should strive for
when possible when possible
yeah he says I learned so much from your
vids I said thank you
I don't know how he's able to continue
the torture here and not resign yeah all
of our pieces are now out which is
pretty awesome Rook C8 okay well I guess
this gives us an opportunity to win the
game in style and we literally have a
thousand ways that we could win here
right literally we could take on A7 we
could play the move Knight C3 to E4
which I like the look of trying to
isolate this bishop although after 94
black will play Knight D5 right that's a
scenario in which we don't want to allow
the Knight to get to D5 and there
already we can't take the Knight because
C takes D5 is going to be a check
so the moment Rook C8 happens out of the
corner of my I've made a mental note to
myself to make sure that when I'm
calculating I don't forget that if the C
Pawn disappears that could be a check it
doesn't matter right now but just
something to to keep track of okay so
let's try to find the most incisive and
and decisive option I think I see what
it is and we don't have to be fancy here
at all the bishop on D7 is the weakest
piece on the board what is it defended
by well it's defended by the Queen the
king and the Knight if we could
eliminate the Knight then we isolate the
bishop and we win the game
we consider 94 but that allows Knight D5
what's a different way to do the same
thing which does not permit Knight D5
it's a simple move yeah Bishop G5
literally just take the Knight and then
take the bishop that's it
that's all there is to it
so for example if black plays Bishop p7
it doesn't help we take the Knight and
then we could even take the bishop of
the rook and hit the queen and Black's
position also simultaneously falls apart
and he loses the second minor piece
yeah if you want to be more fancy we'll
I'll show you a couple of other fancier
wins that maybe we'll find with the
engine but we're trying to play it as
simply as possible Rook C7 all right so
this is where a little calculation can
go a very long way and we barely even
need to calculate so here's what we want
to do yeah you should in in such
situations where there's so much tension
the first thing that you should
calculate is essentially what happens if
you just trade all of the pieces like
what is that going to lead to and it's
often much easier to calculate that than
you might imagine so for instance Bishop
takes Knight Queen takes Bishop Knight
takes Bishop Rook takes Knight and in
that resulting position the game ends
after Queen takes C6 because we're
simply going to win The Rook on D7 but
as an order of operations thing as an
order of operations thing I think it
might be a little bit more accurate for
us to start with Knight takes D7 and
then play Bishop takes F6 and the reason
is that if we take first and then take
on D7 we're giving the black queen a
couple of additional intermediate move
checks
they don't change anything in this case
but we're trying to be as clinical as
possible also it just occurred to me
that I could just take the Rook on D7 we
don't even need to take on F6 yeah we
don't even need to take the Knight that
Knight can be taken on demand
so literally everything is winning here
I think the best is actually just Queen
takes C6
or Rook takes D7 either way just ends
the game on the spot yeah okay we'll
just play Rook takes D7 and pick up a
second minor piece
maximally simple
okay so if we really want it to be
clinical then I would delay Bishop takes
F6 and throw in the move Rook D1 which
we're gonna do right that's pretty easy
to understand but there is one line that
you have to calculate there we're gonna
play Rook D1
the queen has to stay anchored to the C6
Pawn so Queen E7 Queen takes E6 is just
Checkmate if black plays Knight D5 this
is the move that a lot of people I think
would see would see and think oh I can't
do that but you have to force yourself
to keep calculating we already know what
happens after Knight D5 we simply take
the Knight if CD then Bishop B5 with a
pin familiar idea from the very start of
the game if Ed then the check on E1 is
decisive because it wins the queen very
very simple
yeah Knight T5 so we just take it and
whichever way black takes they lose the
queen
hopefully we got a resignation here
yeah at this point it's not even fun
it's not even fun to play because we're
toying with him
CD
and obviously Bishop two B5 winning the
queen and also that is Checkmate Queen
takes B5 Queen B5 is simply checkmate
yeah only 20 moves in
black never developed the king side and
that tells you all you need to know
there we go gg gg thanks for resigning
okay
now obviously in the previous alopin
game which you know if you're watching
on YouTube and you don't remember it you
know you could maybe go through it
pretty quickly or just go through the
analysis phase
in that game we faced the move Bishop G4
which is the more topical continuation
to which we still respawn Knight C3
and the only thing that you have to
remember here if the queen moves away
then again we play D5 that's what
happened in the game and we got an
overwhelming attack but if blackplay's
Bishop takes F3 there's a line that is
it's impossible to come up with this if
you don't know it beforehand
because if you're looking at this for
the first time you you will probably
think the move is Knight takes D5 and
then a fork but that resulting position
is unclear instead you actually take the
bishop of the pawn
and what's even more surprising is you
accept the queen trade
and then you play Knight B5 of course
this is like computer generated idea but
it's not that hard to understand because
black is totally undeveloped and white
has the bishop pair which means if black
plays Knight C2
and white does the same
essentially black is going to have a
much harder time winning whitesnite than
white is winning black snide and the
black king is going to get caught in the
crossfire because white has a light
squirt bishop and black doesn't so
White's got all sorts of checks that
could help the process along I analyze
this in pretty good detail in that last
YouTube video so I'm not going to go
over it again but suffice it to say that
this is the key line you have to know
and the second line you have to know is
E5 in this position to which you also
respond Knight C3 if the queen moves
away then D5 is decisive so Bishop B4 is
absolutely forced now you unpin the
Knight with Bishop D2
the trade on C3 is forced again and E4
is not totally forced but what most
people play
ed494 is just a clear Advantage for
white because of the bishop pair
um and I looked at that as well E4 the
key thing to remember is to put your
knight on E5 very active move
and white is considered to be clearly
better according to Modern Theory the
new testable course uh which I can
recommend also gives this line as an
advantage for white and once again I
looked at some further lines in in that
video
so of course G6 is a decisive mistake
and if you flip the engine on yeah it's
already about plus two and a half but
that's the kind of plus two and a half
where the engine could probably defend
this with insanely accurate play but for
most humans like this is indefensible I
think Queen d8 is actually correct but
here of course black had to bite the
bullet and play Knight B this was the
only move the only way to Stave off
immediate defeat how would we have
continued the attack actually it's not
so simple right you don't just want to
make random developing moves here
because eventually black only needs
three moves in order to deploy the king
side so you can't lounge around and do
whatever the heck you want you need to
play very actively and very precisely
and actually analyzing with the engine
in these types of situations is
incredibly instructive situations where
you know that you need a lot of
precision
the engine can supply you with some
really instructive ideas that you can
actually then apply so for instance I've
turned the engine on it's only goes up
to depth 20 so take this with a grain of
salt but but still it's actually
suggesting Queen A4 check
which to me seems pretty
counter-intuitive because it allows
black to develop a Tempo but that's
actually the point the bishop is super
awkward and now the queen drops back to
B3 hitting the pawn on B7
so if black plays the obvious move which
is B6 then white has the typical idea D6
this is a pretty classic concept when
your queen is aimed at F7 because if
black takes you've cleared the pathway
to the F7 pawn and black collapse this
year black is just not fast enough F7
cannot be easily defended and after
Queen E7 check
how should white proceed what is the
most precise move here who can tell me
and then again a situation where there's
an obvious move but if you look a little
bit more carefully yeah you just go King
D1 you don't go Bishop E3 because you
actually want to get the Rook to E1 and
the game is over
there's just no way to defend every
Knight C5 Bishop G5 everything is uh is
coming fast
so if black plays E6 here then Knight B5
is also game over because the knight's
heading for C7 and now the Knight can be
attacked with Queen A3 black is just not
hasn't completed you know hasn't put his
pants on and we're already checkmating
him
so black has to try Queen B6
and now the engine gives us Bishop B5
Bishop B5 and what is the idea if black
takes it Knight takes B5 and A6 ah
there's a beautiful and this is why
engines are freaking awesome because
sometimes you just see moves and they're
so obvious in retrospect but I would
have never found this in a classical
game it's Queen B3 to C3 with a double
attack on C8 and h8
and after a b Queen AJ the queen is not
a not trappable the queen on h8 cannot
be attacked so it's just chilling there
and on the next move we're gonna bring
the bishop to the rescue to H6
what uh yeah what a weasel the engine oh
Queen B5 Queen C8 is simply made
so after Bishop B5 if black ignores then
we bring the other Bishop out again
Bishop takes C3 Queen C3 hits The Rook
that's an important detail
and now you can see that this is not
going in the right direction for black
Queen A5 castles Knight F6 and now
another very nice move Bishop drops back
to C4 another reason that you provoke
the move Bishop D7 because the B7 Pawn
is permanently weak and on B6 we can
move material with Knight B5 castles and
simply either Knight C7 immediately or
First bishop D2
and Knight C7 wins the exchange with a
huge initiative as well
um so really cool ideas there starting
with Queen A4 check probably in a game I
would be more tempted to give a check on
B5 I think this is the most natural
human move but after Bishop D7 it's a
little bit hard to figure out the proper
follow-up
maybe you want to trade and just Castle
this would be one way to play
and basically attack down the e-file
with the move D6 this also looks really
really good to me and the engine
confirms this is another way to play
black is just not in time right if you
had given black one more Tempo and black
kid Castle in this position it would
basically be equal but if black brings
the Knight out then we're able to take
on E7 and prevent black from castling
this is forced because Queen E7 rookie
one is a pin so rookie one check and
black is lost here just because the king
is so weak and Black's Rooks are not
connected and the queen is coming to B3
these are the kinds of positions that
you just kind of have to sense are are
lost
so I don't want to belabor the point but
I think this is a instructive
exploration of you know how how the
engine tends to attack in these types of
positions
but after an ip4 there's nothing left to
analyze we pick up the night we play the
accurate move 95 and here just the one
little detail where yeah Bishop C4 is
also totally fine but we decided to
bring the queen side out first with the
idea of meeting Bishop G7 with Queen
side Castle so that the Knight is
protected right these types of small
subtleties can really help you win these
games quickly
Bishop C4 E6 castles and the last thing
to clarify if black had played Knight D5
here then again we take on D5
if CD you know the drill Knight takes D7
Queen D7 Bishop B5 the check on C8 is
not scary if DC you can figure this out
yourself it's like 8 000 different
discoveries here
and if black plays e takes D5 then we
simply play Knight takes Pawn the point
is not to win the pawn it's to clear the
e-file for the rook and the game is over
for instance DC rookie she won with mate
coming pretty soon
um well XI Sparks asks so what should
you do if you're trying to use the
engine in a situation like this and the
engine recommends a move that you don't
understand so I want to make a video a
separate video on this but in in short
understanding engine moves is uh you
know very important it's a skill it's a
skill that can be acquired and there are
several tests that you can do if you
don't understand an engine move the
simplest one is to understand what the
next move is so you basically make a
random move in response you move some
pawn and you see what the next move is
and if you don't understand the next
move either then you keep repeating the
process until you understand why you
know the significance of the initial
move which will eventually manifest
itself because every move has a specific
aim another test is to just analyze
right ask yourself well
what move would I play instead and why
is it bad
and that's how analysis works right you
don't always understand the point of the
move immediately but if you analyze and
you explore different options often you
begin to understand things about the
position
so for instance Queen A4 check I think a
lot of people would say well I don't get
it you're just helping black develop
with Tempo but when you analyze you see
that no actually the weakness of the
Pawn on B7
it justifies this loss of a tempo right
as does the fact that the Knight now
can't come out to D7
so it's a gradual process and you have
to be patient with yourself okay back to
the game yeah after Bishop G5 the game
ends because black simply cannot save
any of his pieces and now we played it
very simple one more accurate move Rook
D1 getting the Rook into the game and
winning the queen with Bishop B5 simple
and once again if you'd like a more
comprehensive review of the main lines
here then um I will direct your
attention to the previous alopin video
which you can find in the speedrun
playlist
foreign
[Music]